[Music]
recently married congratulations thank
you and uh
i know that you had
i knew you had a lot of fun at your
wedding and uh and and uh and things got
a little out of hand what did you do
that we got a little you know what i had
such a great day and it was it was the
only one regret i do have i think it was
probably the adrenaline
and i maybe i started drinking a little
bit too early
so i can't remember an awful lot after
midnight and uh i was talking to my wife
the next morning
and uh and i was like i was okay though
i wasn't i didn't like make a fool of
myself or anything in front of and she
said no you were fine you were great you
were gregarious and all of that i was
surprised that you wore the crown for so
long
you you gotta use you wore a crown at
one point it would seem so
and at that time i was like no no no you
were you were you were a disgrace i
can't remember wearing i think you were
making that up just to make me feel
but then she uh she sent me on a picture
yeah
we have the picture this is you
wearing a crown
that's all we really have time for
you you had some other pictures but i
don't think we have time by the way your
wife is beautiful
i love it again she's gorgeous